sixty minutes interview McCabe admits
that his attempt to undermine the
president began almost immediately after
his boss Jim Comey was fired and it was
of course due to Russia I was speaking
to the man who had just run for the
presidency and it she and and won the
election for the presidency and who
might have done so with the aid of the
government of Russia
our most formidable adversary on the
world stage and that was something that
troubled me greatly how long was it
after that that you decided to start the
obstruction of justice and
counterintelligence investigations
involving the president I think the next
day I met with the team investigating
the Russia cases and I asked the team to
go back and conduct an assessment to
determine where are we with these
efforts and what steps do we need to
take going forward
Alan Dershowitz has retired Harvard Law
School professor he's the author of the
book the case against the Democratic
House impeaching Trump and he joins us
professor thanks very much for coming on
so now the suspicions of many are
confirmed by one of the players in it
the Department of Justice discussed
trying to remove the president using the
25th amendment what's your reaction to
that well if that's true it is clearly
an attempted coup d'etat relating to
what your former guest said let's take
the worst-case scenario let's assume the
president United States was in bed with
the Russians committed treason committed
obstruction of justice the 25th
amendment simply is irrelevant to that
right that's why you have an impeachment
provision except the 25th amendment is
about Woodrow Wilson having a stroke
it's about a president being shot and
not being able to perform his office
it's not about the most fundamental
disagreements it's not about impeachable
offenses and any Justice Department
official who even mentioned the 25th
amendment in the context of President
Trump has committed a grievous offense
against the Constitution the framers of
the 25th amendment had in mind something
very
specific and trying to use the 25th
amendment to circumvent the impeachment
provisions or to circumvent an election
is is a despicable act of
unconstitutional power grabbing and you
were right when you said it reminds me
of what happens in third-world countries
look these people may have been
well-intentioned they may believe that
they were serving the interests of the
United States but you have to obey the
law and the law is the Constitution and
the 25th amendment is as clear as could
be incapacity unable to perform office
that's what you need that's why you need
2/3 of the house and 2/3 of the Senate
agreeing and it has to be on the basis
of a medical or psychological incapacity
not on the basis of even the most
extreme crimes which there's no evidence
were committed but even if they were
that would not be a basis in the 25th so
this is not something that Brett and I
challenge any left-wing person to get on
television and to defend the use of the
25th amendment I challenge any of my
colleagues who were in the get Trump at
any cost
camp to come on television and justify
the use of the 25th amendment other than
for physical or psychiatric incapacity I
bet they're doing that right now but
this is an attack on our system I would
say not just on the poster calendar so
thank you very much an attack on our
system it's an attack on the
Constitution thank you
scary